I think it's important to understand that
because of the enormous increase
in house prices, primarily in this country
and in a lot of countries,
people's financial positions now
are very largely a function
of the decision of how much debt
their parents
or their grandparents chose to take.
Okay.
So I wanted to start with explaining
the relationship between debt
and money, because we did a video
a couple of months ago
called What Is Money,
which a lot of people watched.
And in that video,
I basically explained that
our modern monetary systems,
the money system of the UK,
the US or Europe of basically
the whole rich world at the moment
is a debt based money system,
which means that money is debt.
And what I said
at the beginning of that video was that
if we added up the total amount of money
in the whole of society,
it would add up to zero.
And that is because we have a debt
based money system,
which means that for every one person
with £1 of money,
there has to be somebody somewhere
with £1 of debt and it cancels out.
I think that can be a little bit confusing
for some people.
When we think about it
from the money perspective,
but now we can look at it
from the debt perspective.
And I think that makes it a bit clearer
because it should be easy to understand
that the total amount of debt in society
is equal to zero.
And the way that you should be able
to understand that is because we know
that it is impossible to be in debt
without being in debt to somebody.
So if we add up the total amount of debt,
it will equal the total
amount of money owed to somebody.
The amount of money
that everybody owes is equal
to the amount of money
that everybody is owed.
And that is because
every debt has somebody who is in debt
and somebody who is in credit.
And we're going to use that term ‘credit’
to refer to having money owed to you.
So if I borrow £100 from Simran,
then I have £100 of debt.
I'm in debt.
And Simran has £100 of credit.
He is in credit because I owe him money.
So this is the
first thing that debt adds up to zero.
And it's obvious when you think about it
because you know that if you owe money,
then you owe that money to somebody.
Is it possible to owe money to nobody?
But I think as much as it's obvious
when you think about it very often in
our conversation about debt, it becomes
clear that we don't really think about it.
Because, for example,
we know in the last three years
that the UK government debt
has increased by £700 billion.
This very clear, we can check that.
We know that the US government
debt has increased by £8 trillion,
sorry, $8 trillion,
and yet we very frequently act
as if that money has disappeared
and not gone anywhere.
And that is impossible.
That's not how money works.
That's not how debt works.
If the UK Government has gone £700
billion into debt,
we know that somebody
must have accumulated
£700 billion of money
because that is how debt works
and that is how money works is always
a perfectly balanced system.
If somebody is in debt,
somebody has money, If somebody has money,
somebody is in debt.
We have a debt based monetary system
debt is money.
Money is debt the total amount of debt
adds up to zero.
And I think this is super interesting
because in a sense,
as soon as you understand this,
you understand our current economic crisis
much better,
which is that, yes, it is true,
our government has gone £700 billion
into debt, into more debt
than it was already in.
The US government has gone
$8 trillion more into debt.
But those debts are to somebody
and the money that the government
has spent to go into that
debt has gone to somebody.
If we were to find those people
who have that money, we will see that
they have gotten enormously richer,
if we were to tax it back
the government debt would decrease.
I think it's often when we think of debt,
we think of it as sort of wasted resources
resources that have disappeared
We say the government has spent
that £700 billion, it's gone.
That's not how debt works.
If the government goes into debt,
somebody goes into credit
and we can match these things exactly.
We know with certainty
that it will match up.
And I think
when you think about this, it's actually
quite amazing because the total
amount of debt in society
is so enormous
that it's almost difficult to believe
that that money is owed to someone
and somebody has that credit.
And the other side of that,
because the government
debt alone in the UK is £50,000
for every UK adult.
It's enormous.
Five zero, £50,000, which means that
the average amount of money
held in the form of government
bonds must be £50,000 per adult.
And it sort of blows the mind who has
that, that that's just government debt.
All of the mortgages,
your mortgage, your friends mortgages,
your parents mortgages,
your children's mortgages.
Every single mortgage is owed to somebody.
And I think that there's sometimes
a slightly misleading understanding
that these this debt is just appears
and is owed to nobody.
But in reality,
all mortgages are owed to somebody.
And even though your mortgage is
owed to the bank,
banks are in most cases
just intermediaries.
Ultimately, they are lending you money
that comes from the depositors
or from their investors.
So all of this money,
all of your mortgage money,
all of the government debt,
all of the student debt, which is massive,
especially in America,
is all owed to somebody, credit card debt.
And I think when you consider
just how much debt there is,
it becomes almost hard to accept.
I remember the first time
this sort of thought occurred to me
that, you know,
all of this debt is owned by somebody
and the people who own that debt,
they often own it in the form of money.
So let's let's talk about what
it looks like to the owners of the debt,
the people who are in credit.
It looks like holding bonds
in an investment account.
in your pension.
It looks like holding money
in your bank account.
So if you
if you have money in your bank account,
you probably think you just have money.
But what actually happens
is the bank lends that money out.
And essentially that money in your bank
account is somebody else's debt, is money
which has been lent to somebody
and you are a money lender.
You are someone who is in credit
and you are on the other side.
So I think it's
it's worth
realizing that all of this money
is owed to somebody and somebody has
all this money just simply
because the amount of debt is so enormous.
And I think we often sort of
just internally assume
that debt just is to nobody
the debts, the aliens.
We're in debt. Everybody's in debt.
That's impossible.
Society as a whole
has to have a total debt of zero.
And the reason why it seems impossible
is because ordinary
people tend to be on a debt side,
the debtor side of the coin.
So you have your share of the government
debt, you have a mortgage,
but not many people have enormous piles
of cash in the bank or enormous investment
accounts of bonds, and that is because
of the inequality in society.
So bonds and credit
tend to be overwhelmingly held
by rich people.
Now we will get some people commenting,
and it is,
of course, true that if you have a pension
or if you have a large bank account,
you are in credit.
You are one of the people
who has the credit.
But if you look
at the overall distribution
of credit of money
owed to people is overwhelmingly owned
largely by the richest people in society
of course, there will be some owned by,
for example, pensions
and things like that.
Another comment we get
is that we owe all of this money to China
or to foreigners.
And it is, of course true that the UK
as a whole does have a debt to China.
It also has a debt to Japan, but most of
the debt is own is owed internally
and there's a situation happening where
increasingly financial assets are owned
by a kind of international super elite
and they own
the debt of many, many countries,
which means that there are very wealthy
people to whom money is owed by British
people on the British government.
But there are also very well
wealthy British people
who will have the credit
of foreign governments and foreign people.
So don't allow yourself
to be sort of lured into this trick.
Of all the money is all owed overseas
because overseas people also owed money
to British, wealthy people.
The reality is more a situation
of ordinary people
and ordinary governments are in debt to
a kind of international,
super rich elite of which many are British
and many are American,
because America and Britain
and Western Europe are rich countries
and they are creditors.
The money is largely
owed to wealthy people.
In the rich world.
And of course,
what is important to understand
is that every year, every month,
every day, the people who are in debt,
which is you, if you are a taxpayer,
which is your government,
which is you, if you have a mortgage,
pay money to the people who own credit.
So every single day,
a big chunk of your taxes
goes to the wealthy debt holders
and a big part of your
your mortgage payments
go to those people as well.
Now, the next thing I want to explain
is a little bit tricky, but I think it's
important to understand the function
that debt plays in our economy,
which is that debt is a form of ownership.
It and I think the best way to understand
this is to consider
the way in which corporations
finance themselves.
So we tend to know about shareholders,
which is if corporations need money,
they sell shares,
they get money from the shareholders,
and the shareholders give the money
to the company that it needs.
But in actuality, corporations
choose largely
between two ways of raising funds,
which is selling shares to shareholders
and selling bonds, which is essentially
borrowing money from wealthy people
who want to lend money.
And in many cases
they take more than 50% of their funding
from people
who lend the money to them, to creditors.
So when you are running a corporation,
you have a choice between
how do you raise funds from stockholders
or from bondholders?
Who are the people who lend the money?
And when you think about it
like this, you realise that
stockholders and bondholders
are really not that different.
They are both people
that give money to a corporation
and then take a share of the profits
of the corporation.
The way in which the profits are shared
is different.
So the company first has to pay interest
to the bondholders.
Then if there's any money left,
it pays the rest of the profits
to the shareholders.
But in a sense, it's not that different.
If you are a bond holder or stockholder,
you give money to the company
and they give you a share of their profits
going forward.
So we consider often in our mind
the stockholders
to be the owners of the company,
but in a very real way, stockholders
and bondholders are not that different.
And it's the same if you own a house.
So obviously, if you buy a house,
you think you own the house.
But if you buy a house
using a huge amount of debt,
then really your situation is in many ways
similar to when you were still renting.
Right. You know, of course,
there are differences.
You can choose what to put on the walls
and things like this.
But if you're renting a house,
you live in the house
and you have to pay a chunk of money
every month to the owner of the house
to live in the house.
If you're owning with a mortgage,
you live in the house and you have to pay
a chunk of money to the moneylender
every month to live in the house.
So I think it's important
to understand that really
debt is
a form of owning assets.
It's it's not that dissimilar
to simply owning the asset and renting it.
And in both cases, you'll see
if you stop making the payments.
So if a corporation stops
making the payments to the debt holders,
what will happen is legally
the debt holders will be given
possession of the company
because there is a form of ownership.
And if you stop paying your mortgage,
what will happen is your mortgage
lender will take
legal possession of your house
because debt is a form of ownership
and I think it's
it's important to understand that
that basic fact really
that that debt is a form of ownership.
And if you own an asset
with a large amount of debt,
essentially
what is happening is a wealthy person
who has the money to lend you
is buying the asset through you.
And of course,
debt is not the same as ownership, right?
If you own the property with debt, you
you take the price risk on the property.
If the price goes up, you make that money.
If the price goes down,
you lose that money.
Also, you have the the legal risk.
So we have a situation in this country
where a lot of people bought property
and then found that they had to upgrade
the cladding on their property
and the owner had to take the
loss on that.
So if you own
with debt, then you take
price risk, you take legal risk
and you also have to manage the property.
But in a very real sense, you
if you have to pay to use that thing,
be that through owning it or through
having debt, you do not own that property.
So debt is a form of ownership
and it is a way of rich people
buying assets
and not having to worry about the price
going down,
not having to worry about management,
not having to worry about about legal
risk.
Really,
if you think about it from the perspective
of the wealthy lender, it's
kind of he's kind of running a business.
He's saying, look,
I have two ways of getting property.
Either I buy it and I read it to you,
but then I take the risk
of the price falling.
I take the risk of damage, I take legal
risk, or I'll lend you the money.
And I probably won't make
so much money on it because interest tends
to be cheaper than rent,
but you have to take the risk of price
falling.
You have to take the risk of any damage
or legal problems and you have to manage
the property. So really
and I said this
many times, but I think it's interesting
to understand that is a form of ownership
is a way of wealthy people owning assets
and having you manage them.
So in a way,
this way of owning assets through
debt is quite good for the rich, right?
Because I don't have to worry about
if the price goes down.
I don't have to worry about managing it
every day.
I don't have to worry
about any legal risks.
You manage it for me and you still pay me
the interest every month.
I don't have to do anything.
It's pretty fantastic
way of owning assets.
And yet
people overwhelmingly prefer
to own their property, even through
a massive amount of debt than renting.
Why is that
So there are a couple obvious reasons
why people prefer to own with debt
rather than to rent, such as
You know, you can make your own changes,
you can, you know,
paint the walls, these kind of things.
But let's try and focus
on only financial reasons.
Why is it that people
prefer owning property
even with a huge amount of debt
to renting property?
The primary reason, in my opinion,
why people prefer that
is because in the last 30 years,
property prices have gone massively up.
And as
I said when I spoke about debt
as a form of ownership,
when you own with that,
you take the price risk.
So if prices go down, you lose money.
If prices go up, you make money.
And in the last two years, prices
have gone up massively.
So buying assets with debt has been
a really, really good financial investment
for people in the last 30-40 years.
And for that reason, I think
we've kind of internalised this idea that
taking on debt to buy assets is good
because prices always go up.
And I think
an interesting thing is happening here,
which is that
basically
people who
I think it's important to understand that
because of the enormous increase
in house prices, primarily in this country
and in a lot of countries,
people's financial positions now
are very largely a function
of the decision of how much debt
their parents
or their grandparents chose to take.
So if my parents
had chosen to take on four
mortgages or five mortgages,
they would be much, much richer
now than if they did
what they actually did do,
which is to only take one mortgage
on a small house.
And we've created this quite interesting
set of financial outcomes
where we've really, really rewarded
people who took
quite risky economic actions,
which is to take on huge amounts of debt
and to buy huge amounts of assets
and take huge amounts of price risk.
But they have made money
because prices have gone up.
And I think those people often
think that they've made money
because they are very effective
property investors.
But it's probably worth
realising that in the last 20,
30 years it's not just property
that has gone up in price.
Basically every asset has gone up in price
and in most cases
the stock market has outperformed
the property market.
It depends what country
you look, but in most cases that is true.
We've also seen
massive increases in land prices.
Luxury art, luxury cars.
So what really happened
in the last 30 years is
anybody who bought a
tonne of assets will have made money.
It's not actually about property prices
rising.
It's more about asset
prices rising in general.
And this brings me to my final point,
which is the reason that people
who have taken a lot of debt
have made a lot of money in the last 34
years is not really
because asset prices have done well,
but it's because money has been devalued.
And since money is debt and debt is money
debt has been devalued as well.
So anybody who took a huge amount of debt
and then saw the prices of everything go
up, essentially have made money
on the fact that they took
debt and debt has been devalued.
So people who think they made money
in the property market,
they would have made just as much money
if they borrowed
money and bought stocks
or borrowed money and bought land.
So what they really made money
on, when you look at it,
is they made money on their mortgages.
So we have we've created a country
of people who thought they made money,
probably speculating, but really
they made money betting on interest rates.
Essentially, they made money
betting that money would be devalued.
They made money
essentially shorting
the value of money
because they borrowed money and then they
they sold the money
and then the value of the debt went down.
So I think it's quite interesting
in a way that
we've created this
financial incentive structure
that really rewards people
for taking debt,
even though they take on a huge
amount of debt
is not particularly sensible thing to do.
So you know I'm I'm going
to put a video out after this one
about why money's being devalued.
I think it's very true that money
continues to be devalued in our society.
That means debt will be devalued.
That means people who have taken large
amounts of debt will continue to do well.
But it's important to understand
that it's a phenomenally risky
way to make money, and increasingly
it's only accessible to rich people.
You know, if you're
if you're a poor person,
you can't get a mortgage,
you can't buy a house,
you can't do this thing of taking on debt
and buying assets,
which which has made a lot of people rich,
Okay, so that's debt.
Basically,
debt is the opposite of of money
as debt has accumulated,
money must have accumulate.
And this is not really well understood
in the media.
You know,
a lot of sort of stupid things
have been said
like during the COVID crisis
when the government was going
massively in debt, the media was saying,
you know,
we're going to have an economic boom
because people are accumulating money,
people are accumulating savings.
Other people would say
once people spend their savings,
that the economy will go back to normal.
But once you understand that
debt is money, savings are debt,
you would understand that
if the government goes massively into debt
like it did into COVID,
somebody has to accumulate money
and it's impossible for society
to get rid of that money
unless the government pays down that debt.
So I really want to understand
the symmetry here between debt and money.
Money and debt. It's the same thing.
And I think what that allows us to see
is the COVID experience
in a different light,
which is when the government goes into
debt, somebody has to benefit.
And if the government is now
in a situation,
it can't pay for basic services,
That is because somebody has benefited.
And that's why
I continually harp on in this channel
about who has the £700 billion.
It would be enough
that £700 billion to give £14,000
to every single person in the country.
So when the government goes £700 billion
into debt and you don't get £14,000,
it's effectively
the same as the government
taking £14,000 from you
and giving it to the rich.
Okay, so that's it.
Debt is money.
Money is debt
the government has gone into debt.
The rich have accumulated
huge amount of money
that has
led to a massive increase in inequality.
The last final point
I would like to add is
that debt is not the only form of wealth.
There exists real wealth, property,
land, natural resources, factories,
productive machinery.
And who owns
these things is important as well.
So debt
is extremely unequally distributed.
But I think sometimes
people focus on the debt system
and the monetary system
as the only source of our problems,
but we also have phenomenally
unequal distribution of real resources.
And yeah, that all needs to be fixed
if we want to deal with the cost of living
crisis because inequality has increased
and you are seeing that fall
in living standards for ordinary people.
Okay, thank you.
So it's start again.
Once you understand that there is a
form of ownership, you also realize that
that kind of obscures true ownership. So,
for example, the government
wants to keep people owning properties,
but it's difficult for people
to afford properties
because people are getting poorer
and poorer.
The only way that they will fix
that is they will put ordinary families
more and more into debt.
So you see they'll have more 100%
mortgages, might even be 110%
mortgages, longer term mortgages,
much bigger mortgages.
So you still own the property,
but you have way more debt.
And then people feel happy because they
own the property, but they're in debt.
They're much more in debt. See?
So in a sense debt, debt is confusing
because people don't.
It means that you can lose your home
without realising you've lost your home.
Because you still are the
technical owner of the home
But now you're ****ing
half a million pounds in debt, right?
Or maybe £1,000,000 in debt.
If house prices got more, you know,
in 20-30 years, the average British family
will be £2 million in debt on the House,
but they'll still own the home.
You know, I mean,
*???*
You know, and really interesting is if you
look at the situation of the government.
Right.
So the government still owns the hospitals
and it still owns the schools.
But if you look at the total
amount of government debt,
it is now bigger than the total value
of all government assets.
So in a sense, does the government
really own the hospitals & the schools?
It has to pay so much interest on the debt
that it's raised to own them.
See what I'm saying.
So you need to really,
really what you need to consider is
your net wealth, total assets minus debt.
And if you're keeping your assets,
but your debt is going up
and up and up, in a sense,
what's happening is
that is the rich kind of employing you
as middle management to manage your own
house, which they really own.
So I'm saying and now increasingly
a big chunk of your taxes
is going to pay government interest.
You know, if the government didn't
own the schools but it didn't have a debt,
you'd have to pay rent for the government
to rent the schools.
It's the same thing.
So so debt debt obscures true ownership
and sometimes confused confuses
people about the real situation,
about who owns things.
And what you are going to see now going
forward is the government is more in debt.
Ordinary people are more in debt
because house prices are higher.
But you still own your
so don't worry, you own it,
but just pay us all of your money
to be allowed to own it.
You see, I'm saying so
in a sense, owning with debt is very,
very similar to renting.
Very similar to renting.
But of course, house prices always go up.
So you're going to be fine.